رقم واحد ، لقد التزمت أنه إذا تم
انتخابي كرئيسة سنحت لي الفرصة
لتعيين شخص ما في المحاكم ،
فسوف أعين أول امرأة سوداء
في المحاكم ، فمن المطلوب أن يكون لديهم
تمثيل الآن ، فقد تأخر كثيرًا
ثانيًا إذا تم انتخابي  رئيس حكومتي ،
ستبدو إدارتي
مثل الدولة وأتعهد بأنني سأقوم في
الواقع بتعيين امرأة لشغل منصب نائب
الرئيس ، وهناك عدد
من النساء المؤهلات لشغل منصب الرئيس
غدًا سأختار امرأة لتكون لي
نائب الرئيس
رقم ثلاثة ، أنا الرجل الذي كتب
قانون العنف الأسري وأنا الرجل
الذي وضع الحظر المفروض على
أنه لا ينبغي لأي شخص يسيء إلى شخص آخر
أن يكون قادرًا على امتلاك فترة سلاح
لا ينبغي أن يكون قادرًا على امتلاكها  بندقية السيد.  نائب
الرئيس يمكنني المتابعة فقط
لأكون واضحًا أنك التزمت للتو هنا الليلة
أن زميلتك في
الترشيح ستكون امرأة ، نعم